what do you think about country artists
Oliver tree uh
um not a country artist I'm a fan of
Oliver tree I think wants to do a little
bit of everything he's got his errors
he's got his evolutions he's like
Madonna without the talent well you know
without a lot and like a virgin we don't
need to list the things he doesn't have
in comparison to Madonna you know right
have you rated Oliver's albums uh yeah
his his country record and the one
before that so would it do you remember
what you gave them I gave his debut a
seven which he was not generous and um
and then I gave his country album much
much much much lower well tell me what
it was well I think it was maybe around
the realm of a three or yeah
if I was yeah and and frankly a seven is
pretty generous that that's a high score
and fantastic world it was but he was
still very angry about it yeah he's a
weirdo yeah even a light three
yeah you won't even go mid or strong on
the three no we went light on it yeah
very light on it yeah